I officially have my hands on the
Starfield constellation Edition which
I'm going to be giving away to somebody
on Twitch but for now let's unbox it
first up we have a steelbook case inside
we do not have a video game but we do
have what looks like an in-game credit
this is what they look like that's
really cool it's really solid too it's
not plastic which I love the coolest
thing about this is that it actually
contains the code for the game on the
back what a smart way to give a game
code instead of just having it on like a
printout sheet the main part of this
whole package is this very cool box
which is really solid and obviously like
perfectly fits with the aesthetic of the
game here we have the main piece the
watch here is the watch itself it looks
exactly like the one in the game it says
established 2188 how cool is that love
it this is in my opinion such a cool
collector's edition also comes with a
separate strap in case you want to swap
that out it's definitely a big watch
like I feel like it would be huge on my
wrist but I love the attention to detail